you cannot have Innovation or progress
without failure it doesn't exist and if
you truly aren't failing as you're
trying to innovate then you're probably
not pushing very hard because you
haven't broken anything you're making
very very safe choices we could never
put a person on the moon without a bunch
of rockets blowing up first I met a CFO
once I asked him the priorities at the
company and he said efficiency and
Innovation and I laugh and say well good
luck with that you know Innovation is
inherently inefficient because it
requires experimentation experimentation
requires failure much is said about fail
fast I actually I think we overuse the
term failure the problem with the word
failure is it's like the word cancer
it's too broad some people think failure
means experimentation but a lot of
people think failure means catastrophe
and so when we tell our company failure
is good fail fast that literally scares
people we don't want to fail so I think
we need a new word we want to avoid
failure but Falling I think we should
encourage when a kid falls off a bicycle
we didn't tell them they failed we tell
them they fail and what do we tell them
get back up and try again so I don't
want to tell people they fail I want to
see people they fail and I want to
encourage them to try again so I think
we should fall and fall often and I will
judge the quality of innovation not
necessarily by if you fell but how
quickly pick yourself back up and try
again need motivation watch a top 10
would believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Simon Sonic and my take on
his top 10 rules of success enjoy
rule number two seek fulfillment let's
reinforce that point because I think
it's an important one that fulfillment
is a right and not a privilege and when
we go out with our friends for dinner
when we used to be able to do that
um uh uh you know you sit around and
somebody says I love my job and
everybody goes oh my God you're so lucky
like they won something that statement
should be the norm not the exception we
should all get to go to dinner and say I
love my job and it's the one person who
says I don't that's that that we can
that we can intervene
um so yeah I believe it is a right and
we have a responsibility ourselves to to
find a a place where we want to work
with the people that we would work with
rather than just taking the biggest
salary
um that we have a responsibility to take
care of the people around us and we have
a responsibility to speak up and ask our
our leaders to work with us and create a
place where people want to come to work
where we where there's a safe space for
us to take care of each other and feel
taken care of so there's Mutual response
responsibility all around
so when you say you know how do we do it
well it's it requires constant work it's
like how do you stay healthy well I can
give you a whole list of things you have
to do you have to eat right you have to
nurse your personal relationships you
have to get enough sleep you have to
exercise you have to meditate you have
to be mindful you know there's a little
there's like 30 things and you can't do
all those things well all the time it's
a striving
um and uh and when one's doing well
sometimes one one thing falls off it's a
striving and it's the same the the
pursuit of fulfillment is a striving you
know I I think it's you know this is why
I make the distinction between
fulfillment and happiness you know to
seek happiness is a lot easier because
happiness is fleeting you know you you
you get a new job you're happy you get a
raise you're happy you win a new piece
of business you're happy you're given a
gift you're happy you know somebody says
something nice to you you're happy and
that feeling goes away
no nobody nobody walks around with a
sense of happiness for a job they got
four years ago it's gone
um where fulfillment is different
fulfillment you can feel fulfilled by
your work even if you're not enjoying it
today
you can feel fulfilled by your work even
if you if you're having a bad a bad day
you know or or one of your colleagues is
grumpy you can still be fulfilled by the
work it's more it's more uh it's it's
more infinite it's more constant and so
um whereas happiness is you know the
things that lead up to it it sounds more
like an event fulfillment is a striving
it's a lifestyle and you do all these
things like having a just cause like
building trusting teams and working to
be the leader you wish you had in other
words you see your life as a life of
service to those around you whether
you're in a company whether you're an
employee whether you're a leader or if
you're just a parent that you see your
life in service you know to your spouse
your partner or your and your kids and
indeed your community what makes a
community highly functional is that we
view uh that every single person within
that Community sees their responsibility
to serve the community rather than
standing around demanding the community
does something for them well number
three the develop trust I think courage
is external right the reason someone has
courage to jump out of an airplane is
because there's a parachute on their
back it's the external thing a a a a a
world famous trapeze artist would never
try a brand new death-defying act for
the first time without a net it's the
net that gives them the courage
you know the Navy Seals are considered
one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet
and a former seal was asked what kind of
person makes it into the seals
and he said
I can't tell you the kind of person that
makes it in but I can tell you the kind
of person that doesn't make it
he said the Star College athletes who
have never really been tested to the
core of their being
none of them making it
he said the preening leaders who like to
delegate everything
none of them make it in
he says the guys that show up with
hulking muscles covered in tattoos
because they want to show you how tough
they are
none of them make it in
he sent it he said some of the guys who
make it in are skinny and scrawny he
said some of the guys who make it in you
see them shivering out of fear
he said but every single one of the guys
who makes it in when they're emotionally
exhausted when they're physically
exhausted when they have absolutely
nothing left to give
somehow some way they're able to dig
down deep inside themselves to find the
energy to help the guy next to them
in other words the reason these
organizations and these people have the
courage to do remarkable things is not
because of their internal strength it's
because they have the absolute
confidence that there is someone to the
left of them and someone to the right of
them that cares about them
um and they will know that and it's the
quality of the relationships that we
maintain professionally and personally
that give us the courage to do difficult
things
Isaac Stern the famous violinist said
music is what happens between the notes
well something like trust happens
between the meetings you know we few
people think about the importance of
building trust when they go to work or
the what I need to do today to build
trust with somebody like this doesn't
really go through people's minds but we
have Chit Chat as we walk into the
meeting we've Chit Chat when we walk out
of the meeting and we see somebody the
whole they're like oh meant to tell you
something or you knock on someone's door
and be like got a minute and all those
little innocuous interactions over the
course of time like any relationship
build trust it's about setting up the
computer and setting up zoom and having
a work session with somebody you know
like we're not working on the same thing
but I want to work with somebody a work
buddy or having a lunch with somebody
over Zoom or a Monday morning huddle
where we talk about what's on our heart
and minds but we do not talk business on
purpose or Friday uh cocktails that are
just voluntary but the most important
one is to just pick up the phone and
call people and say hey how are you
that level of empathy just check in on
someone and I think we neglect it
because we get mired in the day-to-day
but you know one of you know if you're
organized or disorganized you know
literally keep a list of your team on a
little card next to your computer and
just you know go through it and have I
called this person a while and talk to
spread I'm just going to call and check
in it doesn't matter if something's
wrong or not wrong just check in on them
you know don't wait for something to
Break
um and let people know that they're uh
that there's connection and there's a
way to reach out and say I need help
um because if if if and and the most
important thing is for leaders to be
honest and open about their need to ask
for help
and that that'll work rule number four
love your job they happen to have a
coffee bar uh in the lobby of the Four
Seasons in Vegas and so one afternoon I
went and bought myself a cup of coffee
and uh the Barista working that day was
a kid named Noah
Noah was funny and charming and engaging
and I spent far too long buying a cup of
coffee because I just so enjoyed talking
to Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah
um do you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah said I
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant like is rational I
like the people I like the I like the
work you know I get paid well I like my
job love is emotional it's a higher
order connection right like do you love
your wife I like her a lot right clearly
clearly a different standard right so
when said I love my job my ears perked
up this kid has an emotional connection
to his work so immediately I followed up
and said tell me specifically what the
Four Seasons is doing that you would say
to me you love your job
and again without skipping a beat Noah
said throughout the day managers will
walk past me and ask me how I'm doing
ask me if there's anything that I need
to do my job better not just my manager
any manager and then he said I also work
at another hotel
and there the managers walk past us and
catch us when we do something wrong
they're the managers are always trying
to drive performance and make sure we
hit our numbers he said there I'd like
to keep my head below the radar get
through the day and just collect my
paycheck only at the Four Seasons do I
feel I can be myself
now this is the exact same human being
working at two different companies and
yet our experience of him will be
profoundly different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works you know I
get this question all the time you know
Simon how do we get the most out of our
people people are not a towel that you
ring them out to see how much you can
get out of them
you know it's it's a it's it's it's it's
that's a good one man
[Applause]
[Music]
um
it's a flawed question the question is
how do we create an environment on in
which our people can work at their
natural best and that is the art of
leadership it's creating environment in
which relationships can thrive in which
trust can Thrive and we all know what it
feels like to be on a trusting team
right
um it means that we feel psychologically
safe enough
to raise our hand and say
um I made a mistake
or I need help
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or I'm scared or I don't know what to do
without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us
unfortunately we also all know what it
feels like not to work on a trusting
team where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
we force our people to come to work and
lie hide and fake where they're
pretending that they've made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about Innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas and you have to
create an environment which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to best or significant Improvement also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five help others grow
there's no such thing as a perfect job
and there's no such thing as a perfect
person of course there are things that
we are doing that hold ourselves back
and of course there are things about the
environment in which we work whether
it's the people or the job or the
whatever the circumstances that may also
be holding us back I mean but to see
ourselves as victims is not is not the
up is not the thing
um but rather to seek opportunity and it
goes back to that growth mindset
um uh which is it's what I've learned is
one of the best ways to grow oneself is
to actually help somebody on the team
grow service you know there's an entire
section in the Bookshop called self-help
and there's no section of the Bookshop
called help others and I think what
we've done is we've over indexed on the
whole rugged individualism sort of
self-helpy thing how can I be successful
how can I grow my business how can I
lose weight how can I find love and yet
we forget how can I help somebody else
grow their business how can I help
somebody else find success how can I
help help somebody else lose weight and
find love
Etc and the irony is is the more that we
set out to help somebody else because we
have more objectivity with other people
ironically we actually learn to help
ourselves I I tried this out I did a
little experiment
um a dear friend of mine was going
through a hard a hard time
um a solopreneur
um
the work wasn't going well her marriage
was shaky and she was in a bad place
and so she knows what I do for a living
so she called me up and says would you
spend some time with me I said of course
so every single week religiously we
spent about 90 minutes together and
she'd come over and we would talk and I
would offer some
perspective and some ideas and she'd
feel great for like a day or two and
then she'd go back and we'd get together
the next week and she'd feel great for a
couple of days and then go back in this
repeating pattern went on for quite a
while
and then I remembered my own work which
is the idea of service
um and had a little idea which is to
switch to switch it around and I called
her up and said look I would like some
coaching too and it was genuine I said
you know me better than anybody else I
trust you completely when we get
together for one of our sessions Can it
can I can I use up some of the time can
I tell you what I'm going through
and what ended up happening is we spent
all 90 minutes
talking about my stuff and this went
week after week after week where she was
just the uh advice giver
and strange things started to happen she
started to get more stability in her
work more stability to her marriage her
confidence went up and it was because
she was helping me that she was gaining
all the insights and perspective because
it wasn't personalized it's like sales
training and anybody who's ever gone
through sales training you know this
which is you always do it with three
people you know the person who plays the
role of the salesperson the person who
plays the role of the uh the person
you're selling to the buyer and and an
observer and it's the Observer that does
the learning not the people playing the
roles well in this case you got to see
herself not being not be uh so close to
it gave her objectivity so I'm a great
believer in if you have a problem to
solve it work try and help somebody else
solve that same problem rule number six
study your worthy Rivals there's another
guy who does what I do he writes books
he gives talks Etc his work is extremely
well respected and and I admire his work
as well I happen to hate him
foreign
anything mean to me and we've always had
a very quality relationship when we see
each other professionally I have an
arbitrary hatred of him
and as a result of my hatred
um I'm extremely competitive with him
um I would log on to Amazon on a regular
basis no and check my book rankings and
then immediately check his
and keep in mind I checked no one else's
Just the Two of Us
and if he was ahead I was angry and if I
was ahead I was smug
um and whenever his name came up in
polite conversation I would see
underneath
we were invited to speak together at a
conference where we would be interviewed
together
um and I don't mean like like literally
we would be on the stage together and
the interviewer thought it would be fun
if we introduced each other
um
um and so I went first
uh and I turned to him and I said
um you make me really insecure
and I said all of your strengths are all
of my weaknesses and whenever your name
comes up I get really uncomfortable
and he looked at me and he said funny I
think the same thing about you
the reason I was so competitive with him
had nothing to do with him it had
everything to do with me because his
weaknesses revealed to me because his
strength revealed to me my weaknesses
it's more difficult to take a hard look
at myself and say Here's all the work
you have to do it's much easier and dare
I say more fun to to direct all my
energies at beating him
um that turned out to be an extremely
cathartic experience
um and I learned the value of a worthy
rival
and the funny thing is after that
experience I've never checked mine or
his book wrecking since
um I applaud his work celebrate him want
him to do well because it turns out
working together
we actually are stronger
um and I think this is the same Folly in
business right I I like you know which
is we decide who our competitors are
and then we obsess with beating them
like ABC NBC CBS and fox were obsessed
with beating each other and all they did
was look at Nielsen radiations every
morning
and then Netflix came up and didn't like
who cares they're all they were mounted
a little while because they weren't even
looking they weren't even watching
because that's the arbitrariness of if
you I remember back in the early days
when I first started my career I was in
the ad business and I was Junior dogs
buddy to the junior dog's body and
um I was on the
um competitive analysis team and
basically what that meant was we studied
the competition and we put together
decks to the executives of look what the
competition is doing
and we sometimes would hire outside
Consultants to run you know research for
us and if it was too expensive to study
seven of them we'd cut it down to four
which is hilarious if you think about it
so you're making decisions based on four
and ignore anyway you get my point so
um I think the value of the other
players in your industry of the other
players in the game is not to beat them
because there's no such thing as I said
before you know Best Buy didn't win
anything when Circuit City went bankrupt
um but it's to recognize and respect
them there are some players
who do some or many things better than
you maybe they have a better leadership
stronger culture better marketing maybe
their products are better design who
knows what and instead of trying to beat
them which me couldn't mean you choose
underhanded things or just drop your
price
you actually say okay let's make our
product even better they have revealed
our weakness let's Now work on that
because the ultimate the only competitor
in an infinite game is yourself rule
number seven create your world a just
cause is something a lot more idealistic
it's a statement of the world that you
wish that the the way the world you
wished it worked the the world that you
imagine like we imagine a world as PWC
we imagine a world in which
and then we devote our practice we
devote our energy we devote our
resources to advance towards that cause
and we're going to bring our clients
with us the work that we do takes us
closer to that quote so I'll give you an
example so my just cause our
organizations just cause we imagine a
world so you can see there's that
Forward Thinking which as an aside which
is why we call it vision is because you
have to be able to see it right so we
imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe wherever they
are and end the day fulfilled by the
work that they do that is our cause that
is a cause so just that we would be
willing to sacrifice in order to advance
closer towards that ideal we will never
get there it is an ideal okay and you
can look at organizations or leaders
that have made profound impact in their
Industries or in the world you'll see
these just causes whether it's all men
are created equal right it's a just
cause imperfect in all in its own way
but you can see a nation striving
um I have a dream literally imagining
that one day little black children will
hold hands on the playground with little
white children imperfect in its own uh
in in reality but you can see a a nation
striving
um when Apple and Steve Jobs used to
talk about empowering individuals to
stand up to Big Brother you can see the
attraction to the personal computer
because it literally gives power to an
individual to compete against a
corporation imperfect but a striving and
all of these things become striving that
become incredibly inspiring for for a
Workforce because they feel like they're
contributing to something bigger than
themselves but when you think about
innovation
if you say provide greater value for our
clients
and it's not wrong I have to stress it's
not wrong
but but
when you say innovate around that The
Innovation tends to be more features and
benefits it tends to be tweaking and
efficiencies when you say be the best I
don't even know how you innovate around
that right you can't say some to say
somebody
you know make innovate so we're better
but when you say Innovative way to
advance this the ideas can come from
anywhere inside the organization and the
ideas tend to be a lot bigger okay so
it's not that those things are wrong
that what I'm what I'm offering are what
a a clearer path to embracing an
infinite mindset okay right it's not
that the other doesn't work it doesn't
have value it just has less value in the
infinite game rule number eight ease
your Envy I was uh during covid
um I worked out with a friend of mine
who lives somewhere else we worked out
on FaceTime together we would just turn
on FaceTime and just do the same workout
together basically and one day we were
doing a particularly difficult workout
and I said to her I have some good news
and I have some bad news she says well
what's the bad news I said the bad news
is we're only halfway done she says well
what's the good news I said the good
news is we're already halfway done
and that simple the simple way in which
I present the information literally
profoundly changes the way in which we
do the second half of the the workout
we're only halfway done the rest of the
the workout's a slog it's difficult it's
hard and we don't want to do it we're
already halfway done I mean it's all
downhill we've already done this once we
can easily finish this off and it's
amazing how easy it is to change our
mindset
um uh uh and so it's the same thing here
um we've done it in our own organization
where um we see another organization who
you know I mean I hate to use the word I
use it just for the for the example but
outpaces us I mean we don't care about
that but and and instead of getting all
angry and often bothered and trying to
beat them we say to them we're the
arrival what what you know what strength
do they have that's revealing a weakness
in us and we're like oh my goodness our
website sucks or our e-commerce sucks or
our you know customer service sucks or
whatever it is you know we spend a lot
of time looking at people who we admire
who are in our space who do some or many
things better than us we like look at
their websites we look at their product
we look at the ease of use we're like
wow that's really good you know we don't
have to like it we don't have to agree
with it but we can still complement it
um and I think that's the big thing
people think that you know that you you
know uh that you have to hate everything
that somebody does nonsense you don't
have to agree or like but you do have to
respect
um and uh and quite frankly to put on
blinders and go through the world with
blinders on that there's no one else out
there and they definitely can't do
anything better than you is quite
frankly just stupid because it's just
not true
um you're not great at everything and
you never will be it's an infinite game
it's a game of constant Improvement just
like every person there's no such thing
as a perfect person you know we should
be in a growth mindset constantly trying
to improve every day of Our Lives it's
the same thing and it's even that's
difficult even that's you even that you
can't you can't grow every day even
that's hard you know it's messy and
human and that's the fun and that's why
you go back to trusting teams and why
the teamwork matters so much because
sometimes we can beat up ourselves or
get stuck in a negative mindset and all
you need is one person to walk up and be
like hey worthy rival right
so the nice thing about worthy Rivals is
it's subjective you can choose whichever
person whichever company you want you
don't have internal competition but you
can have attorney work internal Rivals
you know where there are other people
that you compare yourselves to and
you're trying to get better
um uh but you don't want to stab each
other in the back get angry when
somebody else gets a promotion like
we've all had that we've all had that
you know deep down inside we see when
somebody gets a promotion when we didn't
right
um even if we weren't even up for it
um uh that's that's a that's a sign
where necessary change needs to happen
uh in our mindset uh it's easier to do
than you think and when you get in the
habit of it it's absolutely wonderful
rule number nine ask for help tell
someone I need help like I think it is
one of us it's one of these skills that
is becoming fast lost especially amongst
a younger generation which is the skill
to ask for help you know we're all
trying to act so tough you know this
this nation over indexed on the whole
rugged individualism thing you know
where we define success as individual
success
um and and most of our metrics most of
our incentives and almost every job are
individual incentives there you know
there's no team bonus there's an
individual bonus if you hit your numbers
you know
um and uh I think we've we've overdid it
quite frankly uh and I think it's the
pendulum needs to come back uh and and
and we have to remember that we're a
team we're members of teams we're
members of families remember communities
or members of societies and this is
where maslov got it wrong you know
Maslow's hierarchy of needs he says you
know fundamentally at the bottom of the
pyramid is food and shelter
um and he put you know third you know
third up the rung he put a a uh
relationships well I've never heard of
anyone Dying by suicide because they
were hungry I've heard of people dying
by suicide because they were lonely so
in other words it can't be right and at
the top you have self-actualization how
or like I'm all self-actualized looking
down at the rest of you who aren't at
the top of their period what about
shared actualization
you know and the mistake he made is that
there's a paradox which is every moment
of every day we are both individuals and
members of groups and every day we have
to reconcile that do I put myself first
at the expense of someone else or do I
prioritize someone else at the expense
of myself
and the answer is you're right you're
wrong and there's a whole group of
people that says no no you always take
care of yourself first because if you're
not healthy you can't help others and
there's another group of people that
says no you always help others first
because unless you help them they won't
be there for you it's a paradox it
doesn't work it's not so clean
um and this is what we have to reconcile
every day and this is why finding
balance and managing it and the stresses
and trains but the the challenge of
asking for help and relying on our
community really really matters my my
definition of faith is that knowing
you're on a team even when you don't
know who all the players are
um we are surrounded by people who love
us and will take care of us you just
have to ask sometimes because sometimes
they don't know that we need it angle
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is cope with
uncertainty there are so many lessons
that we've learned over the past year
and a half to two years that I think
prepare us to be ready for the next
future
um I got a kick out of during the height
of kovid uh the number of pundits who
said during these unpredictable times I
would smile and say all times are
unpredictable there's never been a time
that was predictable ever
um all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened that reminded
us that our lives and our work is
unpredictable and to Future proof
ourselves means being ready for the
unpredictable
um there's something called an infinite
mindset and those with an infinite
mindset Embrace surprise they find
opportunity in the unexpected that when
something goes Haywire they go oh what
could we do with this versus a finite
mindset which likes to exert control and
keep things very very close and time
frame short because they fear the
uncertain they fear anything that's off
the plan and one of the things that we
have to do to pre to Future proof
ourselves is to embrace things that are
surprises and embrace the opportunity in
uncertainty the other thing that I think
we have to learn on how to Future prove
ourselves is how to deal with stress and
how to deal with trauma
whether somebody did well during covid
business is wise or whether they
struggle business-wise all of us all of
us suffered some sort of trauma and when
I when covet first showed up I called a
friend of mine who's active duty
military and I asked him during when
you're in combat what do you do to
compartmentalize your emotions so you
can stay Mission focused my business
blew up in right in front of me and I
had to focus on my mission of rebuilding
my business I wanted to know how to
control my emotions so I could get the
work done that I had to get done and he
gave me a very sobering warning he said
no one can compartmentalize their
emotions he says we can do it for a
short period of time but everyone will
suffer the trauma of combat sometimes
many months after we get home and he
said you will go through it maybe not
now but you will go through it and uh
sure sure enough about four or five
months in
um I started to feel extremely off my
game
um and uh I called him up and I said can
I just ask you you know uh what are your
symptoms when you go through the the the
trauma of combat I asked no leading
questions I simply said what are your
symptoms he said well one I fall out of
my sleep pattern for some reason I go to
bed late for no reason and I don't want
to get up in the morning and I thought
to myself
yep and he said I become unproductive
and I rationalize it like oh you've been
working hard it's okay if you have an
unproductive day or two but then I have
another and another and another and I
thought to myself yep
and he said I also become extremely
anti-social I don't want to talk to
anyone I definitely don't want to ask
for help
and I thought to myself yup
and I realized I was going through
depression I was afraid to use that word
for fear that it sounded like a
diagnosis but it was Little D depression
that's exactly what I was going through
which is why things weren't working and
so I asked my friend again so how do you
overcome it he said one you have to
force yourself to get back into your
sleep pattern and two you have to force
yourself to ask people for help and
that's exactly what I was doing and I
reached out to friends that I trusted
friends that I loved people who I knew
were dispensers of good advice and I
called them one by one and said I'm
going through this what can I do I also
reached out to friends who I knew were
going through similar things and offered
my support for them because that's one
of the things I've learned in my career
which is the best way to solve your
problems is to help people who are going
through the same thing and so to
understand how to react under extreme
stress to understand and build the
relationship so that when you do go
through something you know who to call
my rule during covet and I called all my
a-type personality friends and gave them
my rule which is there's no crying alone
and the question I would ask every one
of you is if you start to cry who are
you going to call
who will you pick up the phone and just
say I need to cry and tell them what's
going on it is much healthier to know
that someone will give you a shoulder
and be there to support you no matter
what you're going through
I try and read uh news from both sides
of the political aisle not to find the
one I agree with but I want to
understand how it's being reported I
want to know the different narratives
that are being told so that I can
understand those narratives so I can
speak to those narratives I can learn
those narratives and find hypocrisy in
both sides by the way
um I think that the one the one mistake
that we all fall into is to decide that
the ones that I agree with are right and
the ones that I disagree with are wrong
and this this binary notion of right
versus wrong
um is is what's gotten us into this into
this mess in the first place
um life is not so so so so so black and
white in no respect uh it's nuanced and
gray and complicated and messy and to to
understand that we are hypocrites in our
own opinions
um and so is the other side and simply
pointing out the hypocrisy of the other
side is of no help whatsoever what's
more important is supporting that our
own hypocrisy
um and to try and understand that like I
said it's a worthy rivalry thing right
it's not trying to dominate or be right
but it's rather tried to improve and to
grow
um and and so one of the things that I
default to our values
um I'm very proud of the fact that some
of my friendships are with people who
have very very very different uh
political points of view
um who we voted very very differently in
political elections
um and we can go to blows uh talking
about some of the things that the
government is is deciding whether we
agree or disagree with it
um but at the end of the day their
values are are like mine and we and we
believe in taking care of each other we
believe in looking out for each other
and at the end of the day more than
their politics they're my friend and I
learned this lesson the hard way where I
was walking uh I was going for a walk
with a friend who has very different
political views than me
um and she said something and I I
definitely thought it and I fear I may
have said it how can you be so stupid
and I realized I just called my friend
stupid and she completely got angry at
me not because I disagreed with her it's
because I judged her and insulted her
and she you know what she was a hundred
percent right
and what I had to learn in that moment
was to listen
was to replace my judgment with
curiosity and to understand where her
point of view comes from and that I and
that the more Curious I became to
understand that there were actually
things that we did agree upon and though
we may not have agreed upon everything
we actually could find common ground and
that Common Ground always boiled down to
our values and the more that I got good
at listening to her she actually we
became much more open to listening to me
and so as opposed to me hammering my
opinion at her we started to have
conversations and so I think when you go
to a values level politics becomes
secondary but when we let go of our
values then all we have is the politics
which is upsetting I had the opportunity
to work with the Navy Seals and within
the Navy Seals there's actually a more
Elite group within the Cs that's much
harder to get into you have to be a seal
for like five years before you even can
get into this even more Elite group and
I asked the director of training for
this group you know how do you choose
who gets into this more Elite group
within your own within your own culture
and he drew an XY axis he drew a a graph
for me
um uh and on the vertical axis you wrote
performance and on the horizontal axis
he wrote trust the way they Define
performance is how good are you at your
job right your skill set uh the way they
Define trust is what kind of person are
you and the way they put it is I may
trust you with my money I mean trust you
with my life but do I trust you with my
money and my wife's right so
so uh clearly nobody wants a low
performer of low trust clearly clearly
everybody wants the high performer of
high Trust on their team clearly they
learn
is that a high performer of low trust is
actually a toxic team member and they
would rather have a medium performer of
high trust sometimes a low performer pie
trust it's a relative scale over the
high performer of low trust and this is
one of the highest performing
organizations on the planet and they put
huge uh Credence in the trustworthiness
and the character of the team member
over their simple uh performance metrics
in business we're the opposite we have a
million metrics to measure someone's
performance and we have negligible to
know metrics to measure someone's trust
and so you may have a selfish driven
toxic team member who if they're high
performing what do we do we promote them
and sometimes you get to the point where
leadership knows that this person is
toxic and you say you know you probably
shouldn't do something about this you
maybe want to remove them from the team
and they say the same thing they're like
yeah I know
but performance is so good
you're literally just waiting for
something to collapse meaning either
other people will leave or the culture
will start to crack or there's a scandal
or that person will leave because they
get a better job offer they're not loyal
so they may be your highest performer
but they're not loyal
um with the what the seals learn
uh is sometimes these these medium
performance of high trust are your best
natural uh uh best natural leaders the
irony is you know you go to any team
it's actually really easy to find these
toxic team members that's the irony even
though we don't formally measure it go
to any team and ask them who the [ __ ]
is and they'll all point to the same
person okay
um uh and and and and that that's an
opportunity to coach that I don't
believe in firing them I believe in
coaching them you let people go when
they proved to be uncoachable and by the
way if you go to that same team you say
who do you trust more than anybody else
who's got your back no matter what who's
always who's always there to help you
they're probably also point to the same
person who might be your best natural
leader and they may not be your your
best individual performer we don't teach
difficult conversations we don't teach
conflict resolution we don't teach
de-escalation and we don't teach how to
give and receive feedback we don't teach
how to treat ideas we don't even teach
people how to have a meeting
like we don't teach any of these things
and so we're just leaving it up to
chance to hope that somebody knows what
they're doing which we would never let
somebody on the front line do we give
them tons of training on how to do their
jobs so part of it is is the skill set
that we that we can train the other
thing is a lot of leaders I think are
afraid of doing things for fear of
saying the wrong thing and again this
this really lends itself to the training
we need to give our leaders and
especially I think this was really
exaggerated after the murder of George
Floyd
um where so many leaders did nothing
they're not bad people they were just so
afraid of saying the wrong thing or
inflaming a situation or triggering
someone that they chose to to just do
nothing
um and so one of the things we need to
do is teach people how to lean into
tension
um uh and and to learn how to
de-escalate one's own anger or or one's
own trigger and again you brought it up
before which is and replace it with
curiosity tell me more what else I'm
struggling to under stand let me tell
you the story that's going through my
head I think is a really big one that
I've learned which is because I'm
reacting based on my own narrative right
and so they're reacting to my words or
my reaction and so one of the things
that's really helped me is to share
what's going on in my head so that
people have the context of where my
reaction is coming from let me let me
tell you what my history is and what my
background is I'm not saying this is
right or wrong I'm just telling you my
story and I'll say I had this happen in
the past where X Y and Z and so I'm
nervous at your suggestion because in
the past this has happened can you help
me resolve this or do you understand
where I'm coming from
and I think the more we can share what's
going on in the process rather than
simply you know responding with our
answers or our reactions helps the other
person see the way we're trying to see
it and it also encourages us to see the
way they're trying to see it so I think
the more we share it's that
vulnerability word again right let me
tell you my history let me tell you my
baggage let me tell you my background
let me tell you my experiences let me
tell you where my opinion is coming from
um the worst thing the one that drives
me up the wall the one that triggers me
is this is how we've always done it well
why do we do it that way because this is
how we've always done it and my rule is
if you cannot tell me why we're doing it
this way that means it's it's on the
chopping block that doesn't mean it has
to change but but I wanna I want real
explanations of why we do something this
way if somebody can't tell me then then
then it's it's open to being changed I
think one of the essential
skills of being a good coach is
listening and this is a skill that is
not taught in school we don't learn it
on Home unfortunately and and we don't
learn it at work
listening is not hearing the words that
are spoken that's like my favorite quote
that you say go ahead I'm sorry
listening is
I thought I was being original
the the listening listening is not about
hearing the words that are spoken it's
not being able to Parrot back what
somebody said to you listening is
listening for meaning right you uh uh um
you are a good listener
the test for being good a listener is if
the other person feels heard
right say that again right write that
down so so I mean we've all had we just
take it out of the context of business
right we've all had an argument or
wanted to share our feelings with a
friend or a loved one right spouse
girlfriend boyfriend you're sitting on
the couch and you say something's
bugging you and you say can I just tell
you something that's bugging me and they
respond by trying to fix it or they
respond by pointing out the facts that
may or may not align with how you feel
right well that's impossible because
this is what happened and what they're
missing is you are not looking for them
you're not looking for them to compare
the facts of what's being said you just
want to feel heard you just want
somebody to go oh my God that's really
hard yeah I hear it I hear that thank
you for sharing that with me that must
be difficult
that's all I needed right I'll give you
a a a a very funny example of bad
listening so I used to date a girl who's
an air traffic controller air attractive
controllers are breed unto themselves
and it's only about the facts and I woke
up one morning I had something in my eye
and I couldn't open my eye it was
hurting and I'm like flushing it out
with water and nothing's work and I mean
I couldn't even open my eyes to have her
come on like come here come here I'm
gonna look in my eye what do you see
anything do you understand anything and
she looks in she goes like this and she
goes there's nothing there and then
walks away
and I eventually you know whatever it
was I eventually was okay and I went up
to her I was like
WTF right
I'm like I had something in my eye you
just walked away
and she's like there was nothing there
so what do you want me to do
I was like a little sympathy she's like
well that's not going to get anything
out of your eye
listening is standing by my side while
I'm flushing it out with water and go oh
my God that must hurt so much yeah it
does thank you right that's listening
and if somebody can learn to listen and
now now this is where it gets actionable
this is not me just waxing philosophical
and telling funny stories about
listening my friend will godera do how
many of you are
or restaurant people have you ever heard
of 11 Madison Park so at some point in
New York City 11 Madison Park was the
best rest restaurant in the world right
ranked number one and will believes in
this he's he was the former owner he
believes in this concept of unreasonable
Hospitality which is going to what good
services and then going Way Way Beyond
and one of the core tenets of
unreasonable hospitality is learning to
listen and I'll give you an example that
directly impacts your business most
agents don't listen
and I'll give you an example what do you
do what do you do for your clients after
they close on a home right it's very
common we've all we've we've all bought
a home too right which is you walk into
this new home that you just bought as a
buyer and there's a bottle of champagne
in the fridge
there's a basket of flowers on the
dining room table
the same basket of flowers that you gave
to every other client the same bottle of
champagne that you gave to every client
generic I'm a number it's just it's just
rote but if you were listening
while they were looking at all those
homes and they saw this one little room
that was too small to make a bedroom it
was just sort of a stupid little Nook
that nobody really understood why that
room existed in the house and your
client walked and goes I could make this
my yoga room and that's the house they
bought instead of putting a bottle of
champagne in the house this is what will
talks about instead of putting a bottle
of champagne in the fridge why not put a
yoga mat in that room
with a little note that says it's
perfect right
that's called listening and every single
time you go out
every single time you go out with
clients
uh
they are telling you things they're
telling you stories they're waxing
philosophical they're telling you what
they don't like and what they do like
the problem is you're listening to
whether they like big Windows you're
listening to whether they like the view
you're listening to whether they have
two cars and they need three cars or
whatever it is but you're not listening
to the reasons why the why you're not
listening for the meaning and that's
those the little notes you want to make
that make someone feel seen and make
someone feel heard when you're trying to
build uh trusting teams it's you you
recognize that you cannot enforce
certainty uh on people you can offer
goals people like goals
um but what's important is how we get
there not not just that we got there
think of it like uh think of it like um
trying to lose weight right there's
nothing wrong with setting arbitrary
goals or with arbitrary dates which is
by the way how we build our businesses
we want to hit x amount of dollars in
Revenue by probably the end of the year
because that's when we pay taxes it's a
completely arbitrary number somebody
might say we could do better than that
you're like you're right and then we
change the number right complaint works
of fiction that so we're striving to hit
a work of fiction right
um and it's the same when we want to
lose weight I want to lose x amount of
pounds by X date arbitrary right and
we're doing all the things to do that
we'll you know we're exercising eating
well all the things we love standing on
the scale we love a metric there's
nothing wrong with that
um human beings need that we can't run
in a marathon without mile markers it's
actually unnerving we need to know how
fast and how far so the metrics are good
and let's say you hit your goal right
you hit your performance goal just as as
as you uh had articulated amazing you
feel incredible you feel like you've
succeeded here's the problem you have to
keep exercising for the rest of your
life right in other words you don't stop
doing the things that you were doing so
the game hasn't ended it was simply a
waypoint but what I think is more
interesting is what happens if you miss
your goal what happens if you don't lose
the amount of weight that you wanted on
that date and the and the answer is
nothing nothing happens because you're
probably way healthier than you are it
now than you were you're probably on the
easily you can see the trend data you
can see you're well on your way to
hitting your goal you just pick the
wrong date you're easily going to hit it
in another month if you just stick to
your regime business is the same which
is sometimes we miss our goals but the
question is how what's the trend data
you know is the team working well
together is morale High
um is some of it out of our control you
know market conditions and things like
that things we didn't we didn't know
about and so if we happen to miss the
number the problem is how are we
rewarding our people and so many of us
only reward Our People based on if they
hit the number but what if they're
begging borrowing and stealing what if
they simply Rush at the end of the
quarter to to drop their prices or have
some sort of promotion or or or or have
some some trickery they'll hit the
number
and then we bonus them which tells
everybody else I don't care how you hit
your numbers as long as you hit them
well guess what kind of behavior that's
going to reinforce inside our
organization
whereas if you look at the data the
trend data and you reward somebody who's
well on the path what we're telling you
is as long as you're doing a good job
you'll do well in this organization
leaders understand that they are not
responsible for the results they are
responsible for the people who are
responsible for the results and that
skill set is very very different than
just trying to get people to do the
thing that you know how to do better
than them because you've been doing it
your whole life I get asked very often
you know what are the most important
characteristics of leadership vision
Charisma you know I know plenty of
incredible leaders that aren't Big Steve
Jobs Visionaries you know they're just
not and I know some fantastic leaders
who do not have Charisma they're quiet
and super introverted you know and
they're just not that exciting to talk
to and spend time with
um
uh
uh when I say Charisma I mean the
traditional definition yeah which is
more about energy I believe charisma's
undying belief in something and that
they have in Spades but I think courage
I think courage is the one thing that
all great leaders have to have because
we are surrounded by overwhelming forces
every day of Our Lives pushing us to
play the finite game you know if you're
a public company the the markets all
they want for their own selfish game is
for you to make short-term decisions the
pressures are overwhelming
um
if you're a numbers driven person the
pressures are overwhelming if you're in
survival mode the pressures are
overwhelming if you have a spouse who
spends more money than you can make the
pressures are overwhelming uh all the
pressures around us even the way we
treat competition versus rivalry like we
feel like we have to win win all the
pressures every day on us are absolutely
overwhelming for us to be finite and to
to prioritize the short term over the
long term to prioritize the Urgent over
the important and it takes unbelievable
courage to put the important before the
Urgent it takes unbelievable courage to
resist all the pressures coming from
selfish outside parties it comes it
takes unbelievable pressure to do the
right thing when the pandemic struck I
mean my book came out a few months
before the pandemic and so for from a
from for someone like me who like who
loves to observe and like whether the
stuff is true or not you know you sort
of go you know you sort of Wonder is
everything going to hold up or not
uh and as an existential Flex uh is
something that I predicted would happen
either zero once or at the absolute most
twice in a career but when covet
happened we all went through it at the
same time existential flexibility is is
that you're able to make a profound uh
180 degree strategic shift in order to
continue to advance your cause in other
words stay relevant
um uh this is not about the daily
flexibility of business this is we're
talking profound strategic shift here
um and sometimes brought on by pandemic
sometimes brought on by changing
technology or politics or culture or
tastes
um but you're able to adjust
um so for example it's um Apple Steve
Jobs when they're developing technology
in One Direction they just and they
discover this thing called the graphic
user interface that they did not invent
and they decided to walk away from
millions of dollars spent on countless
man hours in order to focus on a
different uh strategic uh position
because jobs believe that that was a
better a way to advance his cause of
empowering individuals to use personal
computers
um that's that's existential Flex find a
friend you love and uh you know one of
those people who if you called them at
three o'clock in the morning you know
they take your call and you would take
theirs
um don't do this with a spouse don't do
this with a sibling uh uh don't do this
with a boyfriend or girlfriend those
relationships are too close
but find a best friend and ask them this
simple question
why are we friends
and they're going to look at you like
you're crazy because it's very hard for
the human brain to put our feelings into
words because the part of the brain that
controls our feelings doesn't control
language this is why we use metaphors
and analogies and why we struggle to
tell people how we actually feel it's
because it's a different part of the
brain and so they're going to look at
you and be like uh
I don't know why are you asking me this
and you say come on I know you've been
there for me uh my whole life and then
you actually stop asking the question
why ironically you actually asked the
question what you say come on what
specifically is it about me that I know
you'd be there for me no matter what and
they're going to hem and haw because
it's hard to put into words don't help
them don't let anybody else help them
and they're going to start describing
you I don't know you're funny you're
smart you're honest you've always been
there for me you go good you play
Devil's Advocate good that's the
definition of a friend what it
specifically is about me that I'd know
you'd be there for me no matter what and
again some will get through this quickly
and some will get through it slowly and
it'll be a struggle and you have to
continue to play Devil's Advocate good
that's the definition of a close friend
what specifically is about me and
eventually they'll give up eventually
they'll stop describing you and they'll
start describing themselves like my
friend said to me Simon I don't know all
I know is that I can sit in a room with
you I don't even have to talk to you and
I feel inspired and I got goosebumps in
fact I'm getting them right now they
will put into words the value you have
in their life and you will have the
emotional reaction you'll either well up
with tears or you will get goosebumps
this puts you in the ballpark this is
where your why lives and if you do this
with multiple friends they will say the
same kind of thing in in fact sometimes
they'll say the same exact thing because
your why is the thing you give to the
world and amongst your closest and best
friends it is the space you fill in
their lives so that's a fun little way
you can find your why first and foremost
we have to understand that there's no
such thing as certainty of outcome and
this is why this is one of the this is a
huge difference between finite mindsets
and infinite mindsets right a
finite-minded leader is afraid of
surprises and does not like uncertainty
which is why they like to work work in
very short time frames because you can
actually affect quite a lot of certainty
if you only think quarter to quarter
maybe year to year but if you start
thinking in five and ten year increments
you we all know we have zero control
over those outcomes so finite minded
players like to play with very short
time frames because it makes them feel
better even though the game is infinite
so it's actually again sort of a stupid
idea
um infinite minded players Embrace
uncertainty and find opportunity in
Surprise and so where something goes
wrong or different and just as an aside
I got such a kick out of when covet
struck you know everybody was talking
about during these uncertain Times news
flash all times are uncertain there's
never been a time in history ever that
was certain all that happened was
something that we didn't expect took
place that reminded us that time is
uncertain and for the finite minded
players the immediate reaction was Panic
right
um what am I gonna do how am I going to
survive and try and double down on the
old way of doing things hoping that if I
just did it more or at least attempt to
do it online that I would that it would
survive right the more infinite minded
players and this has nothing to do with
stress we can still have high stress
with the with with what was going on but
the more infinite minded players saw the
sudden change in their business and saw
and thought Oh okay this is an
opportunity what can I do with this and
instead of doubling down on the way they
used to do things but doing it online
they said okay the times have changed
the way I operate my business have
changed all the things that I used to be
able to do like having lunch with people
can't do anymore
so given what I know now if if I was
starting from scratch I have something
really valuable and important how would
I build my business today to still
provide the value to the people who are
looking for the thing that I offer
and that was their mentality their
mentality was very entrepreneurial their
mentality was very creative
um and they though it may have caused
stress there was an appreciation for the
opportunity we come to work feeling
uncomfortable that some of the decisions
that are being made
don't benefit the good of the employee
that it really benefits this this
artificial constituency that we call the
shareholder which is really just a bunch
bunch of institutional investors there's
this shareholder myth because there's
been a steady decline of the middle
class being involved in the stock market
for years and the whole point of the
stock market was that we all get to
share in the wealth that we helped build
because it's on the back of Average Joe
employees that produce the great wealth
in the nation and the whole point of the
stock market The Genius of the modern
day Corporation The Genius of the public
company was that we all get to share in
the wealth that we're helping produce
unfortunately over the course of the 80s
and 90s we've seen systems produced
where we're seeing the general
population the middle class actually be
less included in in that success and the
readers and I wrote the infinite game
was because I myself got tired of being
told by people in positions of Authority
or people of extreme wealth that I was
naive that I don't understand how
business business works and for many
years I believed them I thought maybe I
am the dumb one right we all kind of
feel that because they have the power
they have the authority they have the
money they know more than we do
but we still go to work and feel
uncomfortable and it turns out that that
discomfort that gut feeling that says
that there's something wrong here turns
out that the majority actually knows
something
and to me this is a World is Flat moment
that that the the the the people who've
learned to game the system that this
discomfort that we feel we're we
actually are right like they actually
don't understand the game they're in
business is an infinite game and when
you play with a finite mindset lots of
people suffer including the companies
that they themselves are trying to build
that's the great irony the great irony
is the way you build great companies is
with an infinite mindset the way you
build great companies is by prioritizing
people before profit the way you build
great companies is will before resources
um both both things important but there
has to be this General leaning where we
can feel when we come to work and feel
like we're part of something bigger than
ourselves where we feel that our work
and our effort is worth more than simply
the money we make how can we ensure that
we're changing with times technology
culture politics and tastes
um rather than just trying to beat our
competitor and you see it across
Industries uh you know uh publishing for
example
um you know the internet showed up and
they they saw it and they thought it was
nice and they you know as it took on
they sort of I guess they were
interested in it they sort of played
defense and then Amazon showed up and
Amazon went to all of them and said hey
you want to invest in this and they all
said no well now they're all playing
catch up they're all playing defense you
know Netflix went to Blockbuster and
said want to buy us and Blockbuster said
no uh the rest of the TV and movie
industry were too busy comparing who had
higher ratings and they completely
missed the fact that Netflix is now
completely reinvented television I find
that fascinating General Motors was
destroying its own electric vehicles in
an in a to protect its old business and
now they're all rushing to catch up with
Tesla I think this is hilarious and it's
the little companies the Netflix's the
Amazons the Teslas that get ignored
that aren't seen as a threat that end up
defining and redefining entire
marketplaces now this is not unique to
small companies big companies can
absolutely redefine the problem is big
companies are more obsessed with their
finite goals big companies are more
obsessed with beating their competitors
and little companies are obsessed with
their Vision little companies are
obsessed with this outsized Vision that
outstrips the resources they have right
somebody says we're going to do this and
everybody looks around and goes we don't
have the money for that we don't have
the talent for that I guess we'll have
to be creative
and I think this is one of the
opportunities for big companies as they
get big their Visions get smaller they
become goals that they can just do a
back plan for there's nothing inherent
that a big company shouldn't be
Innovative but to your point before they
become risk-averse
they become stable
um and at the end of the day it takes
huge Vision what I imagine is a huge
corporation a multi-billion dollar
corporation that someone will say we
imagine a world that's so crazy and so
idealistic that in this large
corporation they all look around and go
we don't have the money for that we
don't have the talent for that I guess
we'll have to be creative
which scares the heck out of
um uh the investor Community but
remember all of those companies were
founded by you know whether it's your
Steve Jobs or all of all these companies
Salesforce they all started by young
people who had no experience and only
had Vision
um and I think that's there's no reason
why big companies cannot uh cannot be
Innovative but I think
it's about pushing their own boundaries
and allowing for entrepreneurship
um an inherent in entrepreneurship is
failure you can't experiment without
failing I remember talking to a CFO of a
big company once and he told me that he
has two priorities for the company uh uh
uh Innovation and efficiency
I I said good luck with that you know
there's nothing efficient about
Innovation because you have to keep
trying something over and over again
there's nothing efficient about that and
for some reason I don't know what it is
companies are obsessed with growth
and everybody they brag we're a hyper
Growth Company show me one article not
10 not 15 show me one article that shows
any data that hyper growth is good for
business and good for the company
there is no data to show that companies
are obsessed with growth actually build
stronger companies because they don't
um and so it is a Fool's errand that is
promoted usually by an incentive
structure that rewards short-term
benefits I think what companies can do
is start to look at their incentive
structures and start rewarding things
like teamwork ethics and and long-term
gain and guess what you'll get the
behavior year reward there's a whole
industry around I think work-life
balance yes yeah it's like there's a
massive industry that's just trying to
teach this and help people with
work-life balance yeah the problem seems
like it's failing treating well it's
treating a symptom isn't it you know
it's
you know it's like so many things in our
life so here's the bad analogy
um so we buy running sneakers and they
have really thick you know this yeah
they have really thick heels tons of
padding in the heel right but that's
because people don't know how to run
right because we land with our heel
which is bad for our joints you know
you're not supposed to have an extended
knee yeah all of it you're supposed to
be a toe planter where your knees are
always bent I mean you know all this
yeah so instead of teaching people how
to run
what we do is we just build shoes with
more padding in the heel
and treat the symptom rather than the
Cause right and uh uh I think it's it's
the same thing you know uh uh we we
treat symptoms instead of the cause
so so the work-life balance thing what
we're doing is instead of instead of
changing businesses instead of changing
the way a business operates and changing
the way in which we teach leaders to
operate with an infinite mindset so that
we more naturally have work-life balance
and let's be Crystal Clear what
work-life balance means you know doing
more yoga does not create work-life
balance right that's the that's the shoe
that's the cushion on the shoe right
yeah the
imbalances I feel safe at home I don't
feel safe at work that's the imbalance
and no amount of yoga or vacation time
is gonna fix that what fixes that
work-life imbalance is better quality
leadership in our businesses
and then what you'll find is the balance
but instead what we do is we have an
entire industry that's treating the
symptom that's putting that's putting
cushion on the shoe to to make us feel
kinda for an hour right that I've
achieved balance you know
but it's just for an hour and you know
we literally Market you know companies
Market themselves as helping provide you
work-life balance unless you're teaching
leaders to the people who are my bosses
then you are not helping me achieve work
like mountains you're helping me numb
the pain yeah let me cushion the blow
we're social animals
um our happiness our joy our success
everything is dependent on our
relationships
um and we respond to the environments
we're in you can take a good person and
put them about it in a bad environment
and they're capable of doing bad things
likewise you can take a person at the
group or even Society has given up on
and you put them in a good environment
and they're capable of turning their
lives around and really making something
remarkable out of themselves
um we are social animals and we respond
to the environments we're in and leaders
are responsible for building that
environment and if you create an
environment in which people feel safe
amongst their own
we will naturally the natural human
response to those conditions is trust
and cooperation remember trust
incorporation are feelings they're not
instructions there's no PowerPoint or
pitch that you can give upon the end
that someone will trust you you can't
tell somebody trust me it doesn't work
that way their feelings
um likewise if you create an environment
where we actually fear each other fear
the people with whom we work the natural
human reaction to that that environment
is paranoia cynicism mistrust and
self-interest that's what happens
there's enough danger outside the
organization there's enough stuff going
on outside that we should have to fear
the people we work with or fear our own
leaders
and most leaders don't get this most
leaders think leadership is about being
in charge no it's not it's about taking
care of those in your charge most
leaders think everybody works for them
nope you work for the people in your
organization it is your responsibility
to take care of them make them feel safe
and they will naturally want to
cooperate and work hard and give you
their blood and sweat and tears to
advance your vision all they ask is you
take care of them make them feel valued
and valuable and the rest takes care of
itself it's like a parent it's like a
coach teach them train them give them
the opportunity to fall and try again
um and and if they fear the leader then
they're gonna take steps to protect
themselves from the leader it's
pervasive in our world today if you work
in an organization where we're at
standard practice for employees to feel
the need to send a cya email after every
single decision they make that is a sign
that they are taking time and energy out
of their day away from doing their job
in order to protect themselves from
their own leaders that's what that is
you know anybody who keeps a file of all
the good things they've done in their
career just in case they need it yeah
that is people taking time and energy
away from doing their jobs in order to
protect themselves from their own
organization
so you can't ask those people to give
you the best of their thinking and be
more productive if you've created an
environment where they're forced to
protect themselves from you you know
and this is what I learned and so it's
all about this environment the circle of
safety there are five practices in order
to lead uh with an infinite mindset
um you have to have a just cause
you have to have trusting teams
you have to have a worthy rival you have
to have a capacity for existential
flexibility and you have to have the
courage to lead
so just cause we have to give our people
something to advance a cause so just
that they would be willing to sacrifice
their interests in order to do so in
other words turn down a better paying
job or frequent business trips or
working late hours and though I may not
like those things I do them because it
feels worth it because I believe in what
I'm a part of here because I feel that
I'm helping Advance because there's no
achieving in the infinite game the goal
is not final achievement the goal is
advancing to progress in the infinite
game and to have that vision of an
idealized state of the world
um that
um all men are created equal right it's
an ideal that a nation is striving
towards that will never actually get
there but will die trying that's the
point and we can offer people the same
thing inside an organization in fact we
have to to give them something to
advance now how is this different from
the why a why comes from the past it is
an origin story everything single one of
us has our own unique why it is our
Birthright it comes from the sum total
of how we were raised as kids it is
objective you have one and you have one
for the rest of your life the only one
right and the rest of our lives are
about making the decisions that help us
uh keep in balance with our why a just
cause doesn't come from the past it just
causes about the future it's about where
we're going right you can have multiple
just causes you can have one
professionally you can have one
personally you can have one for your
family you can have one for your church
and we're involved in all of these
there's massive pressure put on people
especially young people too what's your
vision well we're not all Steve Jobs and
Bill Gates we're not all Visionaries we
don't have to have a vision but we do
have to find a vision that we can find
someone else's vision and we are so
compelled by it that we want to make it
our own that's what it means to go work
for a company with a Visionary leader
that we believe in that Vision so
clearly that we take their vision and we
make it our own and we will happily
contribute our work our effort in order
to advance what is now my vision right
Martin Luther King had a vision he stood
on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial and
told us his vision but his vision became
our vision so I may not have come up
with that Vision but I found it and I'd
like to devote time and energy to help
Advance it even Beyond him we all carry
a narrative
um someone's lazy
um someone stupid
someone doesn't care someone's only in
it for themselves these are narratives
that we carry and the problem is when we
evaluate their behavior through our
narrative we it'll become it will become
self-reinforcing we will see the things
that reinforce our narrative and the
problem is then we'll treat them that
way if we've decided someone's laser
we're going to treat them as lazy so
there's a great exercise to do which is
literally take out a piece of paper and
when we're struggling with someone to
think what are the 20 other things that
could be going on in their life so yeah
number one they're lazy possible it's
absolutely possible number two they're
having trouble in their marriage uh
number three they're
um things have gone wrong and they and
they don't know how to ask for help
number four they're still struggling
with the trauma of covid number five
their kids are flanking out of school
like all of a sudden we realize there's
a lot of other reasons that could
explain their behavior and we will then
treat them accordingly we will treat
them with greater empathy you know
instead of walking to someone's
classroom and saying what the hell
you're you know your performance is
still down I've had this conversation
with you before you got to get your
performance up or I don't know what's
going to happen
or you can walk into their classroom and
say your performance is down we've had
this conversation before are you okay
I'm worried about you we we they have a
problem but they aren't necessarily the
problem and even if ultimately it does
become that they're a bad fit the
culture they're still they are still not
the problem they still are just a bad
fit for the culture they have a problem
we can help them solve that problem by
going to help them relocate to a
different School District where they're
going to be so much happier we're going
to be so much happier everybody gets to
be so much happier so the other story I
was thinking of is the story of Alan
Mullally
when he took over Ford
um Ford is losing money hand over fist
in other words performance was in
Decline and when he sat down with his
most senior Executives and he asked for
a report on how their divisions were
going regular green every single one of
them delivered PowerPoints with all
green slides
and he said at the end of the meeting
how can everything be green if we're
losing billions of dollars
and they just sat there and he had
another meeting same thing all green and
he said the same thing how can
everything be green if we're losing
billions of dollars the problem was the
previous leader if you delivered a red
slide you got fired
and so there is no way that anybody was
going to tell the truth
because their job depended on it and so
one executive took the risk to turn one
slide red
and malali said thank you for the the
the the visibility that's great
transparency now how can we all help him
fix that problem he has a problem he is
not the problem all the other Executives
thought he was going to get fired turns
out he wasn't and slowly but surely
everybody including leadership could
finally get a clear and transparent view
of what was actually going on in their
organization and they worked together to
solve the problems if somebody was
struggling people said how can we help
you rather than I'm fine you're the one
that's screwing everything up so it's a
great way to think about it we are
designed to take care of each other as
social animals it is in our biology that
we will take care of each other this is
why it feels so good when somebody does
something really nice for us with no
expectation of anything in return we've
all had the experience where somebody
does something nice and you're like oh
my God thank you and then they put their
hand out you're like oh it kind of like
ruins the whole experience completely it
ruins it but when they just do it and
they're like no no and you're like
please they're like no no it's my
pleasure yeah you know not only does our
esteem for them go up but it just it
feels good likewise it feels good when
we do something for someone else with no
expectation of anything in return when
we give our time and our energy money
actually doesn't work believe it or not
like if I told you I gave 500 to charity
this morning you'd be like okay that's
great Simon but if I told you that last
weekend I gave up my Saturday and went
to Painted schools in the inner city
you'd be like nice that's really awesome
now the value of my labor was worth a
lot less than 500 and that's the point
right that's the point which is
um we are designed to take care of each
other and there's a chemical called
oxytocin which is the chemical
responsible for our feelings of love and
friendship and Trust when you look at
somebody you adore and you go like this
that's oxytocin when somebody touches
you and says oh my God it's so good to
see you touch creates oxytocin so good
to see you yeah you know it actually
makes us feel closer to each other you
know
when oxytocin is released in our bodies
not only does it make us feel good not
only does it boost our immune systems
but the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies it actually makes us more
generous because the human body is
trying to get us to look after each
other and it gets even better than that
the person who does the act of
generosity giving of time or energy
without expectation of anything in
return they get a shot of oxytocin the
person on the receiving end gets a shot
of oxytocin
and even witnessing an act of generosity
or kindness releases oxytocin it feels
good to see somebody do something nice
and the more oxytocin we have in our
bodies as I said means we're more likely
to do something nice for somebody this
is the biology of pay it forwards it's
the human body's desperate attempt to
get us to look after each other and so
when we create environments where we
allow that to flow it does naturally it
just takes care of itself it's just
biology
um when we create environments where we
restrict that it actually does the
opposite it releases a chemical cortisol
which is the feeling of stress and
anxiety cortisol actually inhibits
oxytocin which means if we work in a
poorly LED organization not only do we
have high stress but we actually it it
actually inhibits empathy and in other
words I'm less likely to even want to
care about somebody because of the poor
leadership and the poor environment
that's been provided for me to work in
right and the more cortisol we have in
our bodies stress goes up anxiety goes
up it affects our immune systems happy
people live longer happy people have
lower rates of cancer diabetes and heart
disease which means when you're in a
position of leadership you're actually
medically responsible for the lives of
these people get the environment right
they will live longer they will suffer
lower cases of disease and they will
probably have happier families because
of it whereas if you're a bad leader
over the course of time you're actually
killing the people working with you our
jobs are actually killing us
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Brendan burchard
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there now that's fine
if that's your job that's customer
service do that that's your job but if
you're an entrepreneur as an example and
you're just checking into other people's
agendas all day to meet all their
obligations and you keep missing your
key priorities